- There are some surprisingly
healthy parts of foods
that we're just simply not eating.
So let's take a look at the parts of foods
that you may have been throwing away
and not eating unnecessarily.
And stick around to the end of the video
to see one food that you should never eat.
Strawberries are one of my favorite foods,
but as it turns out,
there's a whole lot of
health benefits you can miss
by avoiding the stems.
Throw the entire berry into your smoothie,
as the stems are rich in
disease fighting polyphenols
and minerals.
They also contain tannins
that have low pH levels
and can actually help with digestion.
Zest doesn't just mean
great enthusiasm and energy,
but it's also the outer
covering of citrus fruit
and happens to be rich in terpenes
that actually give our
bodies some protection
from cancer cells and
aging from oxidation.
And it's not just the peel, but the pith,
the white part around the flesh,
it contains hesperidin, a phytonutrient
that has been shown to
lower blood cholesterol,
reduce blood pressure and
decrease inflammation.
Outermost part of onions.
Know, the onion won't suck
toxins out of your feet.
Give me the claims, hit me with them.
It will clean your blood!
God, why am I so angry?
But you can boost nutrition of your soups,
stews and rice using onion skins.
They're rich in quercetin,
a flavanoid that has anti-inflammatory,
anti-cancer, anti-allergy,
exercise improving,
brain protective properties.
Just to name a few.
Do aim for the red over yellow onions
to get more of that quercetin boost.
Praised by the liver king himself.
Liver is known as nature's multivitamin
as it's one of the most
nutrient dense foods.
It's incredibly high vitamin
A in the form of retinol,
which is the already active form.
It's a great low calorie
high protein food,
but again, make sure you're
watching your saturated fat
and cholesterol intake.
Broccoli and Cauliflower stalks.
Fun fact.
Did you know, broccoli's
actually a flower.
(audience gasps)
It's easy to look and
think that the green leaves
are the only nutritious
part of the veggie,
but in reality, the stems contain
healthy amounts of antioxidants and fiber,
just like the leaves.
The Sulforaphane found
in the stems and leaves
actually has potential as
a cancer fighting compound.
Watermelon is more than the
perfect summertime snack
because while the bright
red center is delicious,
the rinds are useful as well.
Pickled watermelon rinds
are filled with Citrulline,
an amino acid that helps
relax and dilate arteries,
which can be good for your blood pressure,
workouts and even sex.
And it has more fiber and potassium
than the actual inside of the watermelon.
Eat your heart out.
Might not just be an old saying after all.
As beef heart has a
similar texture and a taste
to a fine steak, yet it's inexpensive
probably 'cause folks
are hesitant to eat it.
But it's actually a lean piece of meat
with a low saturated fat content
in comparison to other meats,
it is considered a high cholesterol food.
So beware.
Carrot tops.
No, I'm not talking about
him, I'm talking about them.
Remember the orange part
is actually the root of the vegetable
and the green leafy portion
which can be tossed in a salad,
added to a salsa or a hummus
have six times the vitamin A
as compared to the orange part.
Pineapple cores might
sound kind of off putting,
but hear me out here.
The entire pineapple, core included
is a solid source of Bromelain,
a protein digesting enzyme
that has shown to have
incredible medical potential
from anti-inflammatory effects
to helping with fungal
and bacterial infections.
It is a little less sweet and firmer,
but if eaten raw, it still
packs the same nutritious punch
as the rest of the pineapple flesh.
There's nothing tongue
in cheek about tongue
or veal tongue anyway.
While it may have a high
cholesterol content,
it is rich in zinc, iron and vitamin B12.
Both iron and vitamin B12
help replenish nutrients
that are low when you're anemic,
while zinc is an important nutrient
to keep your immune
system in tiptop shape,
especially during a pandemic.
Turns out banana peels are useful
for more than just Mario Kart.
Eating a banana whole,
seems rather untasty,
but the peel does become thinner
and sweeter as it ripens.
So maybe you can wait a few days
for the banana peel to develop some spots.
Bananas are no own for
their high potassium content
with a fruit averaging
about 400 milligrams.
The peel contains an additional,
almost 80 milligrams of potassium,
plus plenty of filling fiber.
Banana bread actually
became such a huge hit
during the pandemic,
and a simple way they
start using those peels
is just to throw them
into the banana bread
for a boost of fiber.
Care about your eyesight?
Then you're gonna hear this.
Beat greens contain two phytonutrients,
lutein and zeaxanthin,
which have been shown to protect against
age related eye problems.
One study actually found that
people who ate foods rich in them,
were half as likely to get cataracts.
If you're chopping the
leaves from this veggie,
then you're toss away more
iron per serving than spinach.
Cucumber peels are yummy, healthy
and worth their weight in gold.
Okay, maybe not that last part,
but the first two are true.
Sadly, when you peel the cucumber,
you are lowering the vitamin
K content by about 56%
than if you were to eat it whole.
And vitamin K supports bone
health and blood clotting.
Just be sure to wash it well
to remove the wax coating
that's often applied to prevent
bruising during transport.
And if possible, aim for the organic store
to reduce possible
pesticide contamination.
Full kiwis, including the kiwi skin
have become one of my
go-to late night snacks.
Do you scoop out the
inside with the spoon?
Well, you're missing out.
You can triple the fiber intake
when you eat the entire kiwi.
Just make sure that you wash it well
and possibly go for the organic kind
to cut down impossible pesticide exposure.
While it might make you sick
to your stomach to think about,
an animal stomach shouldn't.
Tripe refers to the edible muscle walls
of the stomachs of animals
like cows, Buffalo and sheep
who have multiple compartments
in their stomachs.
Tripe is low in calories yet
rich in protein, vitamin B12
and the mineral zinc and selenium.
The one food that you should never eat.
Although, if you swallow one whole,
I guess it's not that big of a deal.
Cherry pits.
Inside of them, if they are crushed,
there is a compound known as prussic acid,
which is essentially cyanide.
So do not chew on cherry
pits, spit them out.
Thank you.
Why are people's hands always cold?
I answer that question in so
many more on the streets in LA.
Watch this 'cause I
miss human interaction.
Click there.
As always, stay happy and healthy.
I'll see you in the next video.
See it, click it.
Watch people make fun of me.
They do. Why?